same-same lots of people hate education
secretary betsy device
what's her response to the haters it's
really disappointing and disturbing when
she spoke at the Kennedy School of
Government students held up signs
calling her a white supremacist and
saying students are not for sale our
kids are not for sale of course they're
not the secretary tries to get in a back
door of the school but she's confronted
physically and then lockdown right after
she took office she went to visit this
school but protesters blocked her away
I am undeterred you were undeterred
you're being turned away from the school
the security person had me get back in
the car and we drove away and he said
that ma'am I don't think we should go
back there and I said we are absolutely
going back there you're going to figure
out a way to get me in because they are
not going to win and you got back in the
back in and I had a great visit
some people hate DeVos because she's a
rich Republican go Betsy DeVos is a
billionaire she was born into a
billionaire family she is rich her
father built a company worth more than a
billion dollars then she married into
the amway marketing fortune Betsy DeVos
is primary expertise seems to be in
being a rich person buying your way into
the position ridiculous what you did
give a lot of money to some Republican
senators yes I have been a contributor
over the years I've also been an
activist over the years I think it's
important for people to engage in things
that they believe in but that's not the
point the point is for 30 years I have
been working on behalf of families that
have not had opportunity for 30 years
she's obsessed about giving poor
families a chance to attend better
schools she donated millions of dollars
to charter schools and private schools
and served on the board of school choice
foundations that enrages the education
establishment what she has done is
actually made schooling worse in
Michigan de Vos help bring charter
schools to
and the union boss claims 80% of the
schools the charter schools in Detroit
are failing charters in Detroit are at
the bottom of the list charter schools
in Michigan actually the students in
them are doing demonstrably better than
the students in traditional public
schools and that goes for the city of
Detroit and statewide she's right
Stanford researchers found the kids in
charters performed better choice did
help the whole country could use help
you look at our standing visa V the rest
of the world it has been stagnant for
the last 30 years 23rd in reading 25th
in science 40th in math and we've
tripled spending on k-12 education but
we haven't gotten the results that we've
hoped for and expected why not
the reality is today almost all the
schools that kids go to are still
operating on the industrial model why do
we group kids by age in school why do we
take the summer off because that's the
way it was always done most of it is
based on history and tradition kids get
the summer off because they're needed on
the farm a hundred years ago when most
were a hundred years ago yes if we were
to introduce full-on choice into an
education environment you're going to
have a lot of different approaches if
there were a real choice good teachers
would make more money absolutely good
teachers should be very handsomely
compensated by the same token teachers
who aren't good and really shouldn't be
in the classroom probably wouldn't be
anymore
because nobody would choose their
classroom you know people are not stupid
they know where their kid is gonna do
best I knew which teacher I wanted my
child to have we need to do something
different this country is on a
trajectory to failure ultimately if we
do not turn around how we are educating
kids today devos also acknowledges that
fixing schools is not hurt
tchau not the federal government's job
most schools are locally controlled and
paid for locally deviceless arrogant
than many in Washington told me I'm not
the nation's choice chief all she can do
is encourage states and local
governments to try choice and to get rid
of the rules that get in the way
president Trump signed an executive
order directing her to do that as the
president said local communities do it
best and know it best that's usually
true local control has its advantages